[Informal Talk]
Thank you. Thank you, Stephen. So what we are really going
to focus on here today are the issues that are going to be
most relevant to you graduating from Stanford and also
starting up a startup company in the Silicon Valley and the
type of issues that you are going to face. And you will find
that the issues that you face as an entrepreneur starting a
small company are much different than you are going to face
joining a big company. So if you find a job with Google, you
are probably not going to have very many immigration issues.
They have a very good staff there, and the immigration
service really isn't looking to Google to scrutinize those
cases very much. But as an entrepreneur, unfortunately, it
can also be very difficult in your situation, someone who is
graduating in F-1's status to secure work authorization
after your one-year of OPT. So that's sort of the focus, but
we are also going to sort of just talk about some of the
immigration basic. So you have an idea. Some of you might
already know this but just some of the language that you
need to know to understand how this process works. So we
will talk about that, and then we will talk about initial
concerns for startups and entrepreneurs. We will talk about
temporary visas, and those are things that are going to be
relevant to you once you graduate. Those are H-1Bs and the
TNs and other nonimmigrant visas that will allow you to
start working once your OPT expires. And we will also talk a
little bit about the interplay between your F-1 OPT and
changing status to a longer-term work authorized status like
the H-1B.
And then we will spend very little time talking about Green
Cards because that's probably not something that's that
relevant to you right now but just to give you a brief
overview so you know what that's about and what options are
available to people like you or starting up companies in the
United States. And then finally, just a minute or two on
proposed legislation to help entrepreneurs and startups, you
might have heard of that there is so-called StartUp Visa Act
that was last year that unfortunately didn't go anywhere. We
will talk a little bit about that and what might be on the
horizon for proposed legislation in the future.
Okay. So, I am just going to go through some basic
terminology so you understand this and not only one we go
through the rest of presentation but when you are talking to
potential employers or the Foreign Studies Office here, you
know what this all means. A nonimmigrant is someone who is a
foreign national coming to United States for a temporary
purpose. So if you are all in F-1 student status, you are a
nonimmigrant. You are coming here temporarily for the
purposes of going to Stanford and learning. An immigrant is
someone that's coming to the United States for permanent
purposes. So that's someone who is planning on living here
permanently.
And traditionally, the nonimmigrants and the immigrants were
two very separate things, and you couldn't be a nonimmigrant
with the intention of becoming an immigrant, of living here
permanently. So you had to show, and many of you might have
had to show this, when you applied for your F-1 your
intention to go back to your home country, proof that you
have ties in your home country that your family is going to
be missing you. So that's traditionally how it works, and it
still works for most visa classification. It works that way
for the F-1. However, some nonimmigrant visa classifications
are what we call "dual-intent classifications" and those
include the H-1B and the L-1. And what that means is this
that you can come on an F-1, when you apply for the F-1, you
have to show your intention of coming here temporarily. But
once you are here, you can change to H-1B and L-1 status,
and once you are in H-1B and L-1 status, it's fine for your
intention to live here permanently. So you don't face those
restrictions. When you go to apply for a visa, an H-1B visa,
they are not going to say, "Oh, are you planning on going
home to Germany?" They don't care with the H-1 or the L-1.
So it's a good classification to be in.
Audience
The dual intent has been a de facto rule for a very long
time. Before I started practicing immigration law, it was
actually added to the regulations and the statute I believe
in 2000, or 1999 or 2000. So it's been around for a long
time. But again, it not only applies to H-1B and L-1, and to
a lesser extent E-1, E-2 and O-1 which are classifications
we will touch on.
Finally, lawful permanent resident Green Card holder, this
is someone who has been granted permanent residency. They
are living here permanently. They have no restrictions on
where they work, what they do, they can do whatever they
want so long as it's legal. So nonimmigrant visa - and this
is an important distinction between a nonimmigrant visa and
arrival/departure record. Most of you, unless you are from
Canada, are going to have an F-1 visa with your picture on
it in your passport. That's a nonimmigrant visa. It's issued
by the consular service abroad, either a consular or an
embassy abroad. That allows you to enter the country. The
arrival/departure record is what Customs and Border
Protection gives you at the port of entry when you enter the
country, that little white piece of paper and it has a
handwritten expiration date. Sometimes it's computer
generated. Once you are here, what's relevant is the
arrival/departure record. That's what determines how long
you can stay here.
For F-1s, that period is D/S. They don't have an expiration
date, which means that as long as you are a student, as long
as you are enrolled in school and you have an I-20 that
covers your period of studies, you are in valid status. But
it's important to know this because sometimes people will
say, "Oh, my visa is expiring," the thing in their passport
with a picture on it. That doesn't matter once you are here.
Maybe it's issue for two months. Once you are here, what
controls your period of authorized stay is the I-94. So when
you switch to H-1B or L-1 or whatever you switch to, that's
going to have an expiration date on it and that expiration
date is very important. If you stay beyond that, then you
can find yourself in all sorts of trouble. But as an F-1
student, it's the D/S which means that you can stay here so
long as you are you are enrolled in school and your I-20
covers your studies. Do you have a question or --
Audience
Yes, D/S.
Yeah, we can talk about that later maybe in the after
session. Are there many people here on the J-1? Yeah, I mean
it's very similar. It's the D/S, Duration of Status.
Audience
Once you enter the country?
That's a good way to put it, yeah. I mean it's complicated.
But I bring this up mainly because when you do switch to a
work authorized status, you are going to have an expiration
date and it's very important to keep an eye on that because
if you overstay that, then it's a problem. But yeah, as an
F-1 or a J-1 or you have the duration of status, yeah, if
you stay beyond the I-20 which is issued for the F-1 or the
IAP-66 which is issued for the - or the DS2019 which is
issued for the J-1, that's also an issue but it's not as big
of an issue.
Next thing I want to mention is petition-based nonimmigrant
classification. What that is is usually work authorized
classifications which require usually an employer to file a
petition with the immigration service, get that petition
approved before you can get that nonimmigrant status. So
most of you are in F-1 status, that's not a petition-based
nonimmigrant classification. You get an I-20 from the school
that says yeah, you are accepted here, they are going to
have you go to school, you take that I-20, you apply for an
F-1 visa consulate. With the petition-based classification,
we have to go through the immigration service in the United
States, get their approval on a piece of paper and then take
that and get the visa. And that's important because the
immigration service is not always the easiest government
agency to deal with, and I am going to be careful what I say
because I know I have been videotaped but it's much
different when you are dealing with Stanford and they are
issuing I-20 and then you are going to the consular abroad
and they just say, "Oh, you are going to Stanford. That's
great. Here you go." So those are just some basic concepts.
The next thing that we are going to talk about are initial
concerns for startups, and this is really geared to those of
who you who are thinking about starting up a company when
you graduate. You are on F-1 OPT status or J-1 status, and
you want to start up a company here as one of the founders
or one of the initial employees or maybe joining a startup.
Maybe there is a startup that's already joined that has five
or six employees, and you are thinking about joining that
company as opposed to Google. These are important
considerations. The USCIS, the immigration service, has a
fraud profile that targets smaller and newly-formed
companies. And we have seen the fraud profile so it's not
something, it's not a conspiracy theory. They accidentally
leaked it. It's not on WikiLeaks yet but it was released to
someone to a lawyer inadvertently. So we have all seen a
copy of it. And these are some of the things that matter to
the USCIS, size matters.
Must have commercially zone premise. A commercial lease is
best. So you want to start up a company at your apartment,
and you want to get an H-1B, that's going to be a problem.
The whole ides of Silicon Valley and garage startups doesn't
work if you are on an F-1 and you are switching to an H-1B.
Must have money to pay salaries. There is prevailing wage
requirements for the H-1B which we will talk about. And even
for other nonimmigrant classifications, they want to see
that you have got money in the bank that's going to pay the
salary that's indicated on the H-1B petition. So sometimes
people come and say, "We have got $50,000. We want to start
a company, and my salary is going to be $100,000." It's hard
to do that. They are going to ask where you are going to get
the rest of the money to pay the salary.
Must have working dedicated phone number. This is less of a
concern. We haven't seen it as much but sometimes people,
they have their cell phone and they want us to put that on
the petition and the USCIS is going to call and they are
going to say, "Hey," I mean they want to hear someone's -
this is ACME, Inc. or whatever.
Must comply with all local state and federal ordinances,
obviously, and this sometimes causes confusion. You start up
a company here in Palo Alto, it doesn't require business
license in Palo Alto but they are going to ask for that
anyway. These are the kinds of things that they are looking
for. If you have existing employees, they are going to want
to see payroll records. So maybe you are going to say, "
Okay, we have got three people working for us," maybe they
are all working for equity. But if you don't have the
payroll records, you can't really say that you have got
three employees. They are going to want to see that they are
regular paid employees with taxes withheld. And it's also
helpful to have insurance receipts for services, equipment
etc. Basically, what they are looking for is a lot of
documentation to show that it's an actual business and sort
of the view that the USCIS sees businesses. They don't see
them as startups working out of garages. They see them as
big organizations. Most of the petitions they see are from
companies like IBM and Google. So they want to see all these
little indicators.
Audience
So long as it's legal, it's fine. So yeah, VC funding is
obviously is the way, I mean usually when we are doing a
startup for an H-1B, there is no revenue. So we have to put
on the form, we say $20 million hopefully in VC funding,
usually somewhat less than that. But that's the idea.
Audience
We can address that question afterwards. That's a little bit
more tricky and complicated. The newness of the company
matters to USCIS as well. It's generally difficult for
newly-formed companies to sponsor employees for petition-
based work authorization because they don't have quarterly
wage statements, again payroll records, tax returns, proven
revenue, a track record of doing business, public records,
and information on the web. One of the things that the USCIS
has started doing recently is they have started using Dun &
Bradstreet which is a company that you might have heard of
that tracks data about companies to verify the existence of
companies, which is really a bad idea because Dun &
Bradstreet, frankly, is not always up to date. In fact, I
went to a stakeholders' meeting in DC talking about this new
pilot program of using Dun & Bradstreet data, and the Dun &
Bradstreet data people that were there said, "We have the
data that's usually up to date." And I have my paralegal
look up our data, and it was three or four years out of
date. So I mean it's just another thing that indicates how
difficult today is for smaller companies. The Dun &
Bradstreet data for Google is probably pretty close up to
date. It's not going to be for a startup company or they
might not even be in Dun & Bradstreet.
So in terms of what needs to be done with this, if you are
starting up a company, you are probably going to have to
take all these steps that you wouldn't otherwise have to do.
Go to Dun & Bradstreet, get your company data in there,
start paying employees rather than just have them on equity
and get a commercial lease for office space.
Stealth companies are problematic because there is no
information on the Internet. A lot of times a startup
company, as you know, it's going to in stealth mode. They
don't want to tell people what they are doing. If we try to
file an H-1B in that situation, it can be difficult,
particularly if the company doesn't want to release anything
to the immigration service. There is nothing on the website,
nothing to verify what they are doing.
So the way that we generally handle that is we have an
explanation that this is a stealth company and we provide
some documentation which we say to treat confidentially with
the immigration service describing what the company is going
to do.
An owner employee immigration sponsorship, very difficult
because the USCIS is new narrow interpretation of
employment, which essentially states that sponsored
employees must be controlled by others. So you want to start
a company, you are going to be a co-founder. Let's say you
are going to own 60% of the company. It's going to be very
difficult to do an H-1B for that and other calcifications as
well, but particularly H1B because they are going to say, "
There is no employer-employee relationship because you, the
employer, and you, the employee, are one in the same." So
that's the position that they take right now, and that makes
it very difficult. And really, there is nothing you can do
about that except try and do something where you don't have
a majority ownership.
Audience
No. If you are the only founder, it depends, I mean there is
other visa classifications. Right now, we are sort of
talking about some of the H-1B, the petition-based visa
processes but there might be other options that we will talk
about here. But usually, for most people, H-1B is the only
way that they have. But depending on your nationality and
depending on how much money you are putting into it, there
is other options.
So now, we are going to talk about some of the common
nonimmigrant visa classifications for people like you. First
of all, one that you are very familiar with, F-1, as you
know, when you graduate, you should get a year of optional
practical training. Some of you might be working pursuant to
curricular practical training right now which allows you to
work while you are going to school. The F-1 OPT gives you 12
months once you graduate. Basically, you can work wherever
you want so long as you are getting paid, and it's above
minimum wage I guess.
So I mean that works actually very well for people that want
to start a company because you have that first year where
really no one is looking over your shoulder. The USCIS is
not saying, "Well, is that really work?" The only people
that you have to deal with is the Stanford Foreign Studies
Office, and as I understand, they are pretty understanding
in this, and they are fine with students using their OPT to
start a company.
The next one is the H-1B Workers in Specialty Occupations,
and that's sort of the standard work visa, and we will talk
more about that. But that's for anybody that's working in
the United States for an employer in what's called the
Specialty Occupation, a position that requires a specific
degree in a specific field. And so the quintessential H-1Bs
are engineers, lawyers, those type of positions where it's
easy to identify that you have to have a specific degree in
a specific field.
The O-1, Alien of Extraordinary Ability, that's for people
that have risen to the very top of their field. We often do
that for people that are PhDs or startup founders that have
started other companies, raised lots of money, made lots of
money, those types of things. It's very high standard to
meet though.
And the E-2, Treaty Investors, we will talk more about that
as well. This is something that might work for some of you.
Most countries we have treaties with that allow for
investors - I shouldn't say most countries but most people
are covered by treaties with countries that we have that
allow people from these countries to come here, start a
business, start an investment, an enterprise and get a work
visa to manage that business, to run that business. Now,
there are some catches to that, and we will talk about that,
but it is an option that should be looked at in all cases,
and it's something that we have done for people that have
graduated from business school in the past year.
B-1, Business Visitor, that is a status that allows people
to come here for purposes of business. It doesn't involve
work but you can use that to start a company or look into
starting a company. But once the company is up and running,
you can't really work in B-1 status.
And then there is some other visa classifications, the TNs
for Canada, I don't know...
Audience
Other visa classifications, the TNs which are available to
Canadians and Mexicans, which is a work visa classification,
the H1B1s which are available to Singaporeans and Chileans,
I don't know if anyone is from Singapore or Chile here, and
the E-3s which are available to Australian citizens. So we
will just touch on those very briefly. So if you are not
from Canada, Mexico, Chile, Singapore, Australia, then you
have a harder time.
And thinking about the different options that are available,
we have to ask which classification is best, and these are
questions that I always ask clients with startups to
determine that. When does employee's OPT, if applicable,
expire? What country is the employee from? How far along if
the company is setting up? How much capital has the startup
raised and from what source? "From what source" is very
important so is the amount but "from what source" is very
important. If it comes from a VC in the United States, it
will preclude out possibly other options for investor
research. How much ownership interest will the employee have
in the company? And as I mentioned, that's a relevant
concern because it can be difficult to get a work visa where
the employee that's being sponsored is also a majority
owner. On the other hand, it will open up other options,
potentially for some people. What is the nature of the
business and how big will the operation be? So I just
mentioned this as sort of an introduction. As we go in more
detail to the different visa classifications, you will
understand why these questions are relevant.
F-1 practical training, as I mentioned, is issues for
startups, requires employment so must get paid. So you can't
just hang out on your OPT, unfortunately. You have got to
get money from somewhere. And as I understand most schools
and I think Stanford as well, they are pretty flexible with
that, you don't have to get paid a whole bunch of money but
you do need to get paid somehow. There is two types of
practical training, again the optional practical training,
generally granted for up to 12 months. It's usually post
completion. You can get OPT prior to graduating but usually
people wait, they save it till like they graduate and they
take their full 12 months then.
Must notify the school of the employer, that's very
important, that's sort of a new rule a couple of years ago.
So when you start working somewhere, you have got to go back
to Stanford and say, "Hey, I am working here" and let them
know. You can't have anymore than 90 days of unemployment.
So you can not work for a little bit of time but if you
exceed that 90 days, then you are in violation of status.
And also important is it has to be related to a degree
program. So if you are using your OPT to work as a waiter,
it might be difficult case to make but it's related to your
MBA program.
Curricular practical training is essentially an internship
while you are going to school. So people get curricular
practical training to work at companies like IBM or Google
or whatever. You can also use it with a startup but it must
be part of the curriculum, and it has to be specifically
approved by the Foreign Studies Office here. So they need to
look at what you are doing and I am sure they have some
forms that you need to fill out, and they need to approve it
before you can do it.
Audience
90 days total.
I don't think there is anything new but there are some
specific things about self-employment in the regulations but
we can talk about that. But yeah, OPT, you can use to - I
mean self-employment is you can work as an independent
contractor, for example, on OPT. You get like a 1099 but you
do have to be receiving compensation. So I guess it depends
on what you mean by self-employment if you are just building
a house and not getting paid for it, that would...
Audience
Yeah, that's fine. You can do it but again, you can't just
be self-employed and not making money because that's
essentially not doing anything, or just doing a hobby.
Audience
The way it work is if you use a full year of CPT, then you
are ineligible for OPT. But conceivably, you can do like six
months of CPT and then still have your one year of OPT. Does
that make sense.
Audience
Okay. Let's talk about the H-1B, Workers in Specialty
Occupations. Again, this is the most common work visa. It's
for workers in positions that normally require at least a
Bachelors degree in a specific field, and again engineers
and lawyers are sort of quintessential ones. It does not
require
[inaudible], as I mentioned. There is a six-year maximum
time limit. So people in H1B status can only get six years
total. However, if you start the Green Card process within
enough time, usually that's before the end of your fifth
year as an H-1B, then you can extend your H-1B indefinitely
while that Green Card process is going. And that's very
important for some people from certain countries because
there is huge backlogs for Green Cards. So if you are from
India or China, the backlog could be as long as eight or
nine years. And if you only get six years as an H-1B, then
obviously that's going to be a problem. So they changed the
law in 2000 that now allows you to extend that H-1B
indefinitely while you are waiting for your Green Card so
long as you start the Green Card process soon enough. And
that's something that's unique to the H-1B.
Another important feature to the H-1B is that you can port
from one employer to another before the petitions approve.
So you work at one company, you want to work at another
company, once the new company files the H-1B petition, you
can start working for the new company. That's unique to the
H-1B as well.
[Audience]
No, it doesn't. Unfortunately, question was in case whether
the H-1B six-year limit is reset by going to F-1 status. It
is not. While you are in F-1 status, you don't use that six
years so you still have the balance of what you had before.
However, the only way that you can reset it is being
physically out of the United States for one year.
[Audience]
Continuous year, yeah, you still have the balance.
Yeah. Every time you file a new H-1B petition with a new
employer, it's all the same fees, all the same paperwork.
There are some advantages like the portability, so you can
port from one employer to other. You don't have to wait for
it to be approved but it's the same paperwork. So sometimes
people say, "It's just an H-1B transfer." There is no real
such thing as an "H-1B transfer," it's always a new
petition.
[Audience]
The government fees?
Well, it depends on the attorney's fees, and well it also
depends on the size of the company and whether you want
premium processing and there is a lot of things. But
generally it's going to be for most $4,000 to $5,000.
[Audience]
Well, that's why with a startup, depending on the position
and depending on how big the company is, your immigration
attorney will hopefully tell you that let's wait till it's
approved, rather than having quit, because if it does get
denied, then he is in a hard situation. So I always tell -
if I think it's clearly going to be approved, then I will
say, "Yeah, go ahead and have them change." But if it's one
of those cases that I think the USCIS might give us a hard
time on it, we file premium processing. It's only going to
take a couple weeks anyway. So let's just wait till then.
So challenges for startups and entrepreneurs in the H-1B,
again, the fraud profile which is specifically for the H-1B.
They are looking at the size of the company. And when the
USCIS is adjudicating small company H-1Bs, they interpret
specialty occupation much more narrowly than they do for
large companies, and there are certain kinds of positions,
and unfortunately business positions, which they are going
to scrutinize very, very closely. So if you have a startup
company with five or six people, and let's say it's got $1
million in VC funding and you are hiring a software engineer
with a degree in computer science, does it work for you? You
are probably not going to have a problem with that. But if
you are hiring a business systems analyst or a director of
marketing, much more likely that you are going to have a
problem with that. It's not that you can't do it and the
immigration service has got a little bit better over the
last year, but it is a more problematic case. So that's one
of those cases, if it were a portability case, you might say
let's just wait for it to be approved just to play it safe.
[Audience]
Well, they look at both but usually degree is not a problem.
I mean someone has a degree in engineering and they have an
MBA, they are not going to say, "Well, is that really an
MBA." I heard Stanford is a good school but they are really
looking at it. And the things that they look at is like you
have got five people, why do you need a director of
marketing. So they sort of impose their business judgment in
the process of adjudicating your H-1B.
[Audience]
That's a complicated question. There is a certain portion of
the government filing fees that the employee cannot pay by
law. However, there are reasons that the employee should not
pay other portions of it depending on how much the person is
making relative to other employees of the company. And I
know that's not a very clear answer but just in the interest
of time, we can take that up in the after session if you
like.
[Audience]
Yeah, there is an annual cap for H-1Bs, and I think we get
to that next slide. So I will just wait, and we'll talk
about that.
[Audience]
Absolutely. Well, I mean one tactic or strategy, I am not
sure which, is to try to file an H-1B if it's - you get to
give yourself multiple bites at the apple. So sometimes,
people do that. The company is kind of small now, why don't
we try it now. I mean it costs money obviously, and you are
going to lose all that money if it gets denied. And then if
it doesn't work out, you still have your OPT. I mean there
are some issues with that, there are some logistical issues
with that. But sometimes, that makes sense because one of
the things, and we will talk about this with the cap, is if
the economy starts really moving again, it might be very
difficult to get an H-1B. Now, I think everybody here is
graduating with MBA so you get a special set-aside, your
chances of getting one are better. Again, I am sort of
jumping the gun and talking about the cap. But what happened
in 2007 is that even people with masters, even 90% of them
got H-1B. You had to file on one day. So if you were an
unlucky one in 10, your case was unlucky and you didn't get
picked in the lottery. And so sometimes, it makes sense to
say, "Okay, I've got the year of OPT but let's try filing
now just in case the economy is going to get really, really
good next year and I am not going to have a chance in the
lottery." Again, I am sorry, I am sort of jumping the gun on
talking about the cap.
So the H-1B is problematic, as I mentioned, for executives
and managers because they are not traditionally specialty
occupations. Again, it doesn't mean that you can't make it
happen but it's more difficult and the risk of a denial is
higher. What we tend to do is if we are doing someone with
the masters degree, and MBA, and it's sort of a technical
position and they have an undergraduate technical degree, we
will sort of pin the position on that because that's more of
a specialty occupation.
[Audience]
I mean if you get promoted to CEO, then we have to file an
amendment if you are H-1B, is normally what we do. And if we
were to do that CEO, we would still try and pin it on your
technical background. So this isn't just the CEO, like the
CEO of U-Haul. It requires someone with a technical
background. I don't know why U-Haul came to my mind but...
And again, as we mentioned, it's increasingly difficult
whether the sponsored H-1B employee has ownership interest
in the company. If you have 25%-30% and we have all the
industries of a employment relationship and employment
agreement, offer letter, all that stuff, pay stubs, it's not
likely going to be a problem. But if you own 50% or more,
then it could be a problem.
And finally, downsides of the H-1B, it's relatively
expensive in terms government filling fees. As I mentioned,
it's usually between $4,000 and $5,000 with premium
processing, depending on the size of the company. More
downsides, annual cap, annual cap is 65,000, and of these,
6,700 are reserved for Chileans and Singaporeans. Remember I
said they have a special treaty status for Singapore and
Chile. Well, they took those visa numbers in their treaty
out of the general pot and reserved it for them. And being
that Singapore is a small country and there is not a lot of
people coming from Chile coming here, they don't use that
whole 6,700. So what happens is this that that unused
portion gets put into account for the next year, and that's
where we are at right now this year. So last year, I think
there was only a few hundred H1-B1 for Chile and Singapore,
and they just added those to the - or indicated how many of
those were left over for this year. So we have actually
reached the normal path for fiscal year 2011 which is 65,000
minus 6,700. But because most of that 6,700 is left over
from last year gets added to the pot, so we still have about
3,000 or 4,000 left for this year.
[Audience]
No, fiscal year starts October 1st. Fiscal year 2011 started
on October 1st, 2010. So if you look at the numbers that
were released a couple of weeks ago, and it shows that the
61,000 regular H-1Bs that have been used up, oh no, the caps
have been reached, but it's not because we have these
leftovers from Chile and Singapore last year.
Now, for all of you that are graduating with an MBA, there
is 20,000 in addition to that that are set aside for people
with Masters degree from U.S. schools. That cap for this
fiscal year has already been reached. That doesn't mean you
can't get an H-1B because we haven't reached the regular
cap, it's just that special set-aside has been reached. And
what happens when there is a huge demand for H-1B, as like
there was in 2007, the regular H-1Bs would run out first. So
it really meant something to have those additional 20,000
for Masters degree holders. But what we are seeing is there
is a lot more people graduating with Masters. So it's quite
possible that the Masters cap and the regular H-1B cap, when
the economy gets good, will run out around the same time.
[Audience]
It depends. If you held H-1B status in the last six years,
and you still have time left, you haven't used up your whole
six years, yeah, that's correct. The question was if you
have had an H-1B in the past, you went back to school to get
an MBA, can you reactivate that H-1B without being subject
to the cap, and the answer is yes, if it meets those
conditions.
[Audience]
No, it doesn't. The way that cap works is if you have been
counted against the cap once in the last six years, you are
not subject to the cap. That's just a gloss but it's a
little bit more complicated than that. So essentially, what
I tell people if you have held H-1B status in the past,
chances are you are not subject to the annual
[inaudible].
Another downside of the H-1B, there is a lot of employer
restrictions on it. Unlike most other visa classifications,
the employer has to pay a prevailing wage, and they have to
keep very detailed records on payroll and working conditions
in compliance with the Department of Labor Regulations. So
for startups, that's particularly difficult because you
probably have not very much administrative support.
Everybody is wearing multiple hats, and then you have to
read this long instruction book that we send people that
explains how to do all the stuff. Obviously, for bigger
company, they have a whole department and probably a person
specifically doing that, and that's all they do.
But that is a downside, and part of the reasons that that's
difficult for startups is that when you start a company,
let's say you are going to be the CEO and you want to take a
small salary and just take equity for most of your
compensation, you can't do that with the H-1B. There is a
prevailing wage requirement. You have to be paid what the
Department of Labor says CEO should be making in the area of
intended employment, and that figure is very high. So when
doing an H-1B for a startup, there has to be some sort of
flexibility in what your role is going to be at the company.
If you file an H-1B for a CEO, $150,000, and they are not
going to consider equity or bonuses. It has to be salary
paid at least once a month.
Finally, no spousal work authorization for H-1B. Some other
visa classification that we will talk about, your spouse can
work in basically open market employment while you are here.
It doesn't apply to H1B.
[Informal Talk]
O-1, Aliens of Extraordinary Ability, again, this is for
people that are really at the top of their fields. So
someone who has documented achievements in business startups
or technology, we often do O-1s for them. People with PhDs,
it's usually a pretty good choice. Usually, if the H-1B is
available as an option, we will start there because even
though the filing fees are less for the O-1, it's a lot of
preparation. It's a lot of work, and the person really has
to be able to show a lot of documents demonstrating their
extraordinary abilities. So I am just going to sort of skip
through that because I think that's less important than some
of these other things.
The next thing I want to talk about is the E-2, Treaty
Investor, and this applies to people from a lot of
countries. We have treaties with countries, many countries,
most countries in Western Europe, many countries in Asia,
which allow for people to come to the United States to start
a business and get a visa pursuant to that business and
running that business. But there are some important
restrictions that are relevant to people like you who are
going to be starting up a company and possibly seeking VC
funding.
First of all, the enterprise has to be at least 50% owned
and controlled by nationals of the treaty country. So if you
are coming here, and you are going to start a company, and
you are not going to own at least 50% of it or you are not
going to have other people from your country owning 50% of
it, then the E-2 is not going to work. And that's often the
case because you might be co-founding with some U.S. people
or you might be receiving so much VC funding but you are not
going to have at least 50% ownership. So that's an important
restriction. It's available to people at managerial,
executive, or specialized positions. So if you are running a
business, as an executive or manager, you can qualify. If
you are an engineer or sort of a highly specialized position
at the company, you can also qualify. So it's not only the
investors that can use the E-2. Let's say you start a
company, and you do your own E-2 to run a company, and then
you want to hire someone from, let say it's Germany, and you
decide you want to hire some guy that you know is a great
engineer, he is not going own any of the company. He is not
going to manage it but he is a great engineer. You can hire
that person pursuant to the E-2 classification, and it's a
lot less - it's going to ultimately be less expensive and
less restrictive than the H-1B.
It's also based on a substantial investment in the United
States. So let's say you come here, you are starting a
company, you are going own 50% or maybe more but all the
cash is coming from a VC in the United States, that's going
to be a problem. You have to show that there is a
substantial amount of money coming from the investors of the
treaty country. And it doesn't necessarily have to be money.
It can be equipment. Theoretically, it can be intellectual
property but that's very, very difficult because you have to
provide an objective valuation of it.
Some of the benefits, it allows spouse work authorization.
So if you are coming on an E-2, your husband or wife can
work anywhere he or she wants while you are on the E-2. Very
few employer restrictions, it does not require - and this is
probably one of the best benefits - it does not require a
petition with the USCIS ahead of time.
So again, one of the issues with the H-1B and other
petition-based work authorized classifications is we have to
deal with the immigration service, and they tend to be a
little less open minded frankly. The counselor service is
what adjudicates most E-2 applications, and their training
is more to facilitate international trade and help realize
the goal of these treaties, which is to allow people from
the U.S. to go to that country and people from that country
to come here to invest. So the E-2 I think is much more -
the adjudication of the E-2 is much more reasonable.
Again, the downside, substantial investment in the U.S., so
representative office or sales office, don't qualify.
Processing generally takes much longer than other
classifications depending on the country. In Canada, they
can take several months. In Chile, it might only take a
couple of weeks.
[Audience]
No. I mean there is a lot of documentation that you have to
show with the E-2, much more so than even the H-1B.
[Audience]
It just means that you don't have to file a petition with
the immigration service prior to getting classification. You
apply directly at the consulate or embassy abroad.
[Audience]
Substantial investment depends on the nature of the
enterprise. So if you are starting a hotdog stand, the
substantial investment is going to be a lot less than a
factory.
[Audience]
My role with them, the absolute minimum is $100,000. There
is nothing in the regulations that says but we won't do an
E-2 unless there is $100,000. If someone says that they are
going to open a semiconductor fab, and they say their
investments are $100,000, obviously that's not going to
work. It just really depends on the enterprise. And you
know, when doing an E-2, we need a business plan that all
has to make sense in terms of the business plan. If you have
this amount of investment, is that going to work for what
you are planning on doing. So I am going to just sort of try
and go through this. The B-1, visitor status, again, does
not allow work authorization but it is a status that you can
use to explore starting a business and actually start a
business. So you can come on a B-1 business visitor, or the
visa waiver if you qualify if you are from a visa waiver
country, and use that, talk to potential investors, look for
office space, even hire people. But once the business is up
and running, you need to switch to L-1 or E-2 status if the
company is qualified.
[Audience]
Yeah. I mean basically, when you are actually start
receiving money from clients, or I would say even before
that, getting paid if you are - definitely, if you are
getting paid by the company, or you definitely need to be in
work authorized status. But even if you are not getting
paid, and the company is starting to generate revenue, you
really should be in a work authorized status. There is
nothing that really delineates that in the statute of the
regulations but...
[Audience]
The B-1? It depends on - if you come in on a visa waiver, so
if you are from a visa waiver country, it's 90 days at a
time. Then you have to leave, and then you can come back. If
you actually apply for B-1 Visa, it will only be granted for
up to six months at a time. And often times, they will grant
it for much less depending on what your purposes are. So if
you say, "I am going to a seminar in Las Vegas for two
weeks," then they are only going to grant it for two weeks
possibly. So it really just depends.
[Audience]
Well, again, we go back to the some of the initial concepts
here. The visa, the expiration date on the visa stamp is
irrelevant once you enter the country. What's relevant is
the I-94. That determines how long you can stay. So you have
a B-1 visa stamp that's valid for 10 years but your I-94 -
but you didn't enter on a B-1, right?
[Audience]
[Informal Talk]
When you come in on the B-1, they would grant it for usually
six months, not allowed to receive salary or compensation
from U.S. source, offer your services for higher. So that's
another thing that comes up. You start a company, and you
are starting to do stuff for other companies, and you really
can't do that, or other activities involving local
employment.
Okay. Just real briefly TNs, if you are a Canadian, that's a
classification that might work. It allows you to skip the
immigration service. Downsides with that, very limited
occupational classification, so there is no executive or
regular management type of position under the TN
regulations. It's for very specific positions like engineer,
accountant, lawyers, etc., etc. So oftentimes, it doesn't
really work for people like you that are starting up a
company even if you are a Canadian or a Mexican.
H1B1, again, we touched on this, it's very much like H-1B
but there is a set-aside for Chile and Singapore. The
advantages of that, if you qualify, are that first of all,
it doesn't go through USCIS, you apply directly at the
consulate or embassy, filing fees are much, much less
expensive.
E-3, again, that is also very much like the H-1B in terms of
what the requirements are but it's not petition based. If
you are an Australian, you can apply directly at consulate
or embassy in Australia. There is a separate quota. It's not
taken out of the regular H-1B cap at $10,000.
The next classification we will talk about, and I am going
to keep this brief as well because I don't think it's
applicable to too many of you, is the L-1A and L-1B
multinational manager. Let's say you have a company that you
started or you work for abroad, and you work there for at
least a year. And when you graduate from Stanford after your
two-year program, you want to go back and start a company
here in the United States with that company, a subsidiary
essentially. The L-1 classification theoretically should
allow you to do that. If you worked at a company abroad for
one year in the last three years, of course, I would be
cutting it very tight because you are going to school for
two years, you can work for a subsidiary parent or affiliate
of that foreign company in L-1 status. So just to go back to
that example, you have a company of maybe 10 people in
Belgium, and you are coming here for your MBA, when you
graduate, you are going to start up a subsidiary of that
company in Belgium here in Palo Alto that makes chocolate or
something.
So that just seems like a good option. The problem is this
that even more so than the H-1B, the USCIS hates L-1 for
small companies. The chances of a denial for a small company
on L-1 are extremely high. So we almost never do this for
startups. We do it where there is no other option or we know
that we have a fallback. So let's give it a shot, if it
doesn't work - because there are some advantages of the L-1,
if you get it, compared to the E-2. If it doesn't work, we
will do an E-2. That might be a situation where we do the L-
1. And I just mentioned it so you might hear about it, say,
"Why don't we do that" if you have that situation. It's
very, very difficult.
[Audience]
You can't unless it's related and unless it meets those
qualifications. So if you are working for, let's say, a
subsidiary of the Belgian chocolate company here and then
you want to switch and work at Google, it's not going to
work because there is no relationship between Google and the
Belgian company.
Okay. I am just going to talk a little bit more about the
cap-gap issue, and that is the situation where all of you
might find yourself in where you have your one year of OPT
and then you need to switch to H-1B. Because of the limited
filing season for H-1Bs, oftentimes what happens is this
that when your OPT expires, there is no H-1Bs left. Right
now, we are looking at H-1Bs for fiscal year 2011 being
reached in the next couple of weeks, maybe a month or so. So
if you don't already have an H-1B approved, and you have
your OPT, once your OPT expires, then you might be in a bad
situation, depending on when it expires.
The regulations now allow for what are called "cap-gap
provisions." This means that if you file an H-1B for the
next fiscal year, so that would be fiscal year 2012, before
your OPT expires, then your OPT work authorization will be
extended till the beginning of the next fiscal year. So
where this might come into place is let's say you are
graduating in the spring of this year. Your OPT is going to
take you till June of 2012. It's 12 months, it will take you
from the time you graduate till June 2012. You file an H-1B,
the soonest that you are likely going to able to file an H-
1B is April 1st, 2012 for the next fiscal year. The problem
is that before that fiscal year starts on October 1st, your
OPT will have expired. This cap-gap provision means that you
can extend your H-1B until the beginning of the fiscal year.
Does that sort of make sense? Or that just clears mud.
[Audience]
Yeah. That applies to you. The other thing is STEM
extension, which was mentioned, it wouldn't apply to an MBA
student. If you are graduating in a STEM field; Science,
Technology Engineering, or Mathematics, you can actually
extend your OPT for 17 months so long as the employer that
you are working for is enrolled and E-verified, which I won'
t go into, and that's regardless of whether an H-1B is
filed. The cap-gap thing, which is applicable to you, only
applies if you file an H-1B within the requisite time
period. So that's just a very short summary of that. But if
you have questions about it, feel free to contact me.
Green Cards, again, I don't think this is too relevant to
you now because right now, you are probably just thinking
about getting a work visa once you graduate. But just to
give a broad overview of some of what might be relevant
classifications and considerations, one issue for startups
is financial resources. Whenever you do an employer-
sponsored Green Card case, you have to be able to show the
company's ability to pay the salary. So if you are saying
that you are going to make $100,000, they are going to want
to see proof that you can do that with either tax returns,
financial statements or payroll records. And obviously,
that's difficult for startups.
Immigrant intent, that might come into play. Some people
want to start the Green Card process with a startup or it's
some other classification while they are on F-1 OPT status.
That's difficult because the F-1 OPT is a strict
nonimmigrant status, and you could face problems traveling
and reentering the country if you are starting the Green
Card process. Before embarking on the Green Card process,
you should talk to a tax advisor. There are implications in
terms of taxes.
And now, just real briefly, means of sponsorship. Most
people who are employer sponsored as Green Card holders do
so through PERM Labor Certification and that's a process
where the employer tests the U.S. labor market to determine
whether there is any qualified U.S. workers who want the
job. And of course, the intention here is to make sure that
no U.S. workers have been displaced to protect the U.S.
workers. What that means for startups is that is difficult
because as a startup, if you are a founder or a co-founder,
you are probably going to have some ownership interest in
the company. And if you have an ownership interest in the
company, and it's what's considered a closely held company,
which a lot of startups are, the Department of Labor is
going to want you to disclose that when you file a PERM
application, and it's going to be very, very difficult to
get that approved. So that's a very important consideration
because the other means of Green Card sponsorship are very
difficult.
When the company gets to a certain level, and it gets
diluted with venture capital, we might be at the point where
we could say well, it's not closely held anymore. But while
it's closely held, I wouldn't even want to file a PERM
application for someone that owns 5% or so of the company.
EB1, alien of extraordinary ability, this is very similar to
the O-1. It's just the standard of review is much higher. So
this is for people that are very top at their field. This
might be an executive who has done well and made lots of
money with previous companies. It's also done for actors and
performers and musicians and other things. But that's a hard
standard to meet, particularly in the business field. It's
much easier for someone who has got a PhD or they have a
Nobel Prize or something like that. If you have a Nobel
Prize, by all means, let me know.
Multinational managers and executives, this is very similar
to the L-1, the L-1 classification that we just briefly
touched on. So if you have a company abroad that you are
coming here, and when you graduate, you are going to open a
subsidiary or you are going to join a subsidiary, and you
are going to work in a managerial capacity or an executive
capacity at that company in the U.S. and you served in a
managerial executive capacity at the company abroad, then
you should qualify as a multinational manager executive. But
again, for small companies, that's difficult. It's difficult
to show that because if you only have four-five employees,
and you are saying that you are the CEO, the immigration
service is going to say, "the CEO of what." They want to see
big companies with lots of employees.
And finally, the EB-5 Investor Visa, and you might have
heard of this, but this is a Green Card visa classification
that allows for people to get a Green Card if they are
investing $1 million, and in some cases, $0.5 million
depending on if it's in a targeted economic area, to start a
business, it creates at least 10 jobs. And there is a two-
year conditional residency requirement. So what you have to
do is you have to take the money, start the business, start
buying stuff and get space and all that, and then you file a
petition saying, "Oh, yeah, here is my business, here is my
business plan. I put in the money. It's legal, I have got it
from legal means." And then they give you a two-year
conditional Green Card. And at the end of that two years,
you have to show that you in fact did or are likely going to
create the 10 jobs that you are required to, and that the
business is still running. Now, important aspect of this, it
has to be your money. You can't use someone else's money;
you can't use VC funding. It has to be your own money. And
they are going to trace it, they can go back five years to
make sure that that's your money and you got it from a legal
means.
[Audience]
Yes. If you get your Green Card through Google, then you are
a permanent resident, you can do whatever you want, or if
you get your Green Card through marriage.
[Audience]
It depends on your background. Right now, it's going very
quickly through PERM Labor Certification. It also depends on
if the PERM is audited. In some cases, they are audited. In
that case, it takes much longer. It depends on your academic
background. It depends on your nationality - or actually not
your nationality, excuse me - the country that you are born
in. And in some cases, it might depend on the country your
wife was born in, or your husband. So there is a lot of
factors. But just to give you an example, someone that's
working for Google or some other established company, they
have a Masters degree, they are in a position that requires
a Masters degree, and they are born in Canada, and Google
starts the PERM process, it might only take three or four
months to get the PERM taken care of based on current
processing times. And then the rest of the process may be
six or nine months. So the best case scenario is a Green
Card in about a year.
Worst case scenario, you are born in India, you are in a
position that only requires a bachelor's degree, that might
be eight or nine years.
[Audience]
Usually, most companies, most of my clients, they wait a
year. They want to see you are working for a year. Startups
might have more flexibility. They want to track the best
talent. So they will do it right away for you. But most
companies, they have a one-year policy.
Okay, I know we are out of time but I am just going to
briefly mention this and then we can move to the other room,
the EB-6 Green Card category, that was a proposed law. It
was started last year. You might have heard about it. This
would allow people like you to get a Green Card by raising
VC funding. So unlike the EB-5 which requires it to be your
own money, the EB-6 will allow you to raise VC funding to
get a Green Card that way. Well, the law didn't go anywhere.
So unfortunately, it failed and Congress didn't pass it. But
it's possible that it would be reintroduced in the new
session of Congress, and it might go somewhere.
[Audience]
I think that's the question maybe we should wait because
that requires more questions, because it really depends. I
can't just say $1 million, because it also depends on what
you are doing, people you are hiring, if you have office
space and how much you are going to own, that kind of thing.
[Informal Talk]